good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy monday
and happy kickoff day to toast friends
and family week we are kicking off an
amazing week while jackie's on vacation
how nice for her
with an amazing slate of guest co-host
and today i am so excited humbled and
honored
to finally welcome my friend amanda you
probably know her better as not skinny
but not fat on instagram host of the not
skinny but not fat
podcast amanda welcome to the morning
toast thanks for having me you're so
awake today that's what i do you wake up
yeah i went you by the way i literally
was following me on instagram i'm like
these [ __ ] at the park like i guess
because you have a kid like you leave
your house before
like it was the craziest thing i'm like
did she forget we have the toast [ __ ]
at the park
you wake up like oh whoops there i go
um like when people are like sleep now
you know it's like annoying because you
can't
do that but it's not like you wake up at
seven where you're like seven is fine
like you wake up at like
five seven is not fine what time do you
sleep
for seven well you also wanna have a
life so you're like
you're like should i go to sleep when he
goes to sleep at 7 00 pm
no i want to be cool and stay up until
11 but then you get like
and you watch so much tv like when do
you have time to watch it when you're
sleeping during the day
yeah i have so many like questions about
logistics about
like being a mom while also being
obsessed with pop culture because and
which leads me to
a point i just wanted to discuss very
quickly we're going to talk about you
but
but first let's talk about myself
because i need to clear up some of the
rumors
that um just started spreading over the
weekend about me that i'm pregnant
and i don't know and how many ways i can
let you guys know i was literally
talking about on the podcast last week
how like i literally don't have kids for
a while like
i am not pregnant i drink every single
night of the week
i literally was hungover for 24 hours
yesterday i just posted a tick tock
there's this trend i know you don't
really like tick tock right well
i think i'm too old for it no yeah
and i think that there are a lot of
different like like
nuances that i don't like a lot of
things are funny yeah but a lot of
things i don't get like the thing that
went
viral that uh selena gomez recreated
yeah that was wait i was supposed to
laugh i didn't even grin i didn't even
nose exhale i didn't do anything i was
legit like wait why is she saying that
and if you're like you know you have to
remember the original and then i watched
the original and i was like
no i still don't get it which one blue
hair for the teen vogue party
or the other one where she was like
mouthing off some audio mouthing off the
audio about like the pregnant girl
yeah it wasn't funny and also selena
gomez's love her not good at tick-tock
so i don't i don't know if i would use
that as an example okay that was just
my latest one but there is there was
this trend where you you play the song
from in the heights and it's like a song
about gossip
and you tell your friend like a piece of
gossip that you just heard so i did it
with ben because i heard like a
hilarious piece of gossip about someone
we went to college with
it was nothing groundbreaking i just
said it and everyone was like
she's pregnant and then my tick-tock
went viral which i was very excited
about but then like i was like oh my god
more and more people are thinking i'm
pregnant i got 600 000 views
i'm not pregnant leave me alone i was
telling ben a piece of gossip about a
kid we went to college with so i just
wanted to clear that up
please leave me alone um but back to you
wait i have a question though do people
dm tick tocks to each other
yes you can okay me and margo my younger
sister we always
so do you think it went viral because
people were like oh my god is she
pregnant
i just think it went viral because i was
using a trending audio and like doing a
trend that was really popular
that day like it was tick tock is like a
very interesting algorithm and if you
have to spend a lot of time on it to
like understand how it works
so i feel like i'm getting better at it
i still don't have like a unique
perspective or point of view like
i don't really give people a good reason
to follow me i just like have a lot of
fun
you know yeah the more you consider are
you with a little mike behind a green
screen
no see that i could never take myself
seriously
it's like my aesthetic as you know and
people that follow me know it's like a
non-one
yeah it's like you like it's whatever
like just [ __ ] on this like it's ugly
it's not like kalyn miller keys from the
bachelor
like it has no it's not curated it's not
curated at all so for me to like green
screen
and take a little mic and drop audio in
i literally thought when it's first of
all i started disliking it from the
dances
yes of course because i don't know how
to do dances and it like made me feel
left out of course
right so that's how i started hating it
until i was like oh it's not only dances
but with the dances when i had to
picture what it looks like i thought
there was a little like
tutorial on the bottom i didn't realize
that people were spending
hours learning it which again like leans
into the like
i need more instantaneous [ __ ] i can't
be planning out a [ __ ] tick tock and
then praying it goes viral because i
hear every one time without like it went
viral
and i mean no offense to your amazing no
it's really sad it's really sad
for sure you're amazing tic tac i'm sure
it was like
art but a lot of them i feel like go
viral by mistake by the way i spend
hours on one tick tock for to get 13 000
views i put up a piece of [ __ ] i'm like
yeah whatever let me just get something
up
a million views like it's actually crazy
you cannot plan and that's what
that's what's so fun about it it's just
like the wild wild west you know
that's your like adventure well i'm
surprised you don't like tick tock
seeing as how you are literally addison
ray's number two biggest fan because i'm
number one
you're not number one did she send you
her merch um
no because she knows i didn't need it i
already bought it to like one of your
things
all right shut up okay like we get it
you're the number one fan okay
no i'm not i just really think and i
even today i posted a picture of her i
just i love that she's like
first of all i really think she's a nice
person me too she's really nice to fans
she knows where she came from she's not
like excuse me get the [ __ ] away from me
sorry am i cursing and i'm not allowed
to oh no curse [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
so she's so nice and i've heard like
from people that have met her
um i feel like she looks like a real
young girl which is so important
um and i just like her vibe
i feel the exact same way like i'm in
love with her like i just think she's
such a good role model for kids that's
what i've been saying and people like
really no you could find something wrong
with anyone i choose not to be that type
of person because i'm not a karen
yeah but i just think she's great i
think she's funny i think like it's so
cool that she's like made her whole
family famous with her like bringing
everyone up with her
and like if i was her i would have done
exactly every business
professional career move she has made
since she first started her tick tock
i would literally do the exact same
thing
end up at courtney carnegie's house oh
whoops whoops just landed here yummy
oh my god genius move genius i'm
obsessed with her i know and i
got so many people into her song you're
welcome eddie it's um
such a good but it's such a good song
you say you're ripped
like i'm sorry and the white outfit that
she wears that's britney vibes that's
britney 2001
dream within a dream to her vibes
honestly i'm actually glad you're not on
tik tok because
it would have ruined it for me like they
made a lot of fun of her music video
especially like that one particular
dance move where she
do you know what i'm talking about no
tell me oh wait like when byron created
yeah it's like
you know she's just like the resting i
love it i'm obsessed with it though
everyone was like what is this dance
move and they were all like making fun
of it on tick tock but again
they streamed her song and made it even
bigger i really need for her to come out
with the new music so i can get it she
is i know
like we don't have a really stateroom
and like just i just feel like we're
i've been
waiting for like a pop star that has
like
the whole thing and people are haters
you know such big like with the ufc
thing it wasn't even real
and reputable media outlets are putting
this story up as if she got hired by the
ufc
got fired because she put up that
journalism tweet oh my god no that what
no we were talking about it last week
for sorry i'm like it was a funny joke
like it was a funny tweet right people
are so [ __ ] sensitive yeah
and like that's just the world we live
in now where like people with platforms
are
getting jobs getting opportunities it's
like when you talk about the usc thing
about like those paul brothers who are
fighters now like
that's just the world we live in like
when you have a platform you are an
influencer a celebrity like you just get
access that's just the world we live in
and like it was a joke
and also it was a joke if it was real we
could still make this argument but she
literally went on like a guest
hosting gig instagram like is anybody
saying anything about kristen cavallari
being on e news or like every single
person that comes everyone it's so
stupid yeah
i mean we do kind of do that i remember
when someone was on you news and this
was years ago for you
um i'm not going to say hello tell me
later i'll tell you and you were like i
can do that
yeah and i mean we all feel the same way
you're like how did you get that job and
you start [ __ ] researching and seeing
where she went to school and you're like
oh she interned for
right of course when i was in college i
was a communications major and i
remember like my first day of like
communications 101
everyone had to go around the room it
was like a small class and say what they
wanted to like do with their lives
every single [ __ ] in that class was
like i want to be the next giuliana
rancic and it's like girl
e news got canceled so your dreams are
okay but like that's what everyone wants
to do like it's a com
there's like so few jobs in that in that
industry and there's so many people who
want them
so true so it is what it is just as for
all the girls who thought they were
going to be the next julian rancic and
then e news got cancelled
your news got canceled justice for them
oh
justice oh yay um if you feel the need
to issue justice for anyone that pink
ass
will roll over yeah you can borrow it
from jackie but you have to give it back
okay
um okay so we have a great show for you
guys today we are gonna get amanda's
insight onto a bunch of stories that i
really picked custom to you because i
know you're really passionate about a
lot of things
kravis britney and luckily over the
weekend there was a lot of things going
on monday's shows are always very
exciting we've got a lot of catching up
to do so
i'm so glad you're here to help me thank
you so much for being here you're
welcome and if you guys like what you
hear check out amanda's podcast
you get gets great guests and you're
hilarious
oh thanks not skinny but off that
podcast correct yeah and you're on
correct
and i was on it and it was a really good
show correct correct
so we're gonna dive in correct to the
best five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
canva pro we've discussed canva pro here
many times about how it's literally the
backbone of our business
and now they're the sponsor of today's
episode canva pro is an easy to use
design platform that has everything you
need to design like a pro
whether you're a professional designer
or just getting started canva pro can
help
boost you and your team's productivity
and creativity it's quick easy and
affordable
it's a quick easy and affordable way to
design whatever you need
no matter what you're creating or
sharing canva pro has everything you
need in one place including a collection
of over 75 million
premium photos videos audios and graphic
plus canva pro comes with time saving
tools that simplify
and speed up the creative process you'll
get all this and more in just
one canvas subscription we use canva for
everything our guest cards all of our
graphics every time we say something
inspirational here on the morning toes
which you know
is very frequently we make graphics on
canva pro it's the best subscription and
it's totally worth the money
you can design like a pro with canva pro
right now you can get a free 45-day
extended trial when you use our promo
code
just go to canva.com toast to get your
free 45-day extended trial
that's c-a-n-v-a dot
m e slash toast canva dot me
slash toast canva dot me slash toast all
right
first story let me just open my ipad
jackie usually does this so i'm just um
hoping i'll be as good as her we're
gonna discuss
the free brittany movement and all of
the drama that happened over the weekend
there was a lot
of family airing their dirty laundry on
instagram which always makes me sad
always so from page six jamie lynn
spears writes about peace after britney
slams the family did jamie lynn spears
just respond to big sister britney
calling her out
jamie lynn 30 posted a vague message
about peace along with some sexy mirror
selfies
just hours after britney posted a
searing social media message aimed at
jamie lynn
their father and the pop star's critics
so jamie lynn wrote on sunday
may the peace of the lord be with you
and your spirit
britney 39 on saturday shared a lengthy
profanity-riddled instagram post amid
her fight to end the longtime
conservatorship that has ruled
practically every aspect
of her life so she she posted on
saturday this really long thing the key
takeaways were
she wrote this for those of you who
choose to criticize my dancing videos on
social media
look i'm not going to be performing on
any stages anytime soon with my dad
handling what i wear say do or think
i've done that for the past
13 years then she pointed the finger at
jamie lynn and added
i don't like that my sister showed up at
an award show and performed my
songs to remixes so
they seem to be like subtly nodding to
each other because when jamie then
posted may the peace be with you of the
lord
brittany posted again may the lord like
go [ __ ] yourself or something like
essentially so they're really like not
even trying to be subtle
men what and then jamie lynn changed the
caption
oh yes she did may the lord peace be
with you
so it was lord something and then
brittany was like may the lord
[ __ ] you and then jamie lynn changed it
to two emojis which
that i feel like if we were like no it's
just coincident she's laura she was lord
the change of the cat also i need to say
something quick
please what urgency did jls
have to post those mirrors did you get
married you get engaged are you yeah
what are you announcing like i feel like
are you is she leaning
into the drums she really does not need
to be active on social media right now i
completely agree
and i i i'm fully in agreement because
one of the pictures her hand was in her
tit a lot of like people were like
excuse me the lord and i don't know if
you saw i don't know if you saw
last week when she um after she had made
those
series of instagram stories that were
compelling yeah she then made some
instagram stories that she was no longer
going to be sharing photos of her kids
on social media
and she was like kind of being all
dramatic about it like she had gotten a
bunch of death threats which
is terrible and you have a child you
know um but she was like
kind of being like um like a little
dramatic like you guys
i'm really not feeling safe sharing
pictures of my kids so she shared a
picture of them with a flag over their
face
well why don't you just not post a
picture if you're not going to share
your kids anymore i feel about emojis in
general but i mean that
i mean i do that too but it's not my
decision my sister doesn't want her
child on social media so like
but i still look pretty in the picture
right i should be here
yeah but it's her she's like i'm not
going to share kids pictures of my kids
anymore and then she shares a picture of
her kid with an emoji on it
just don't share it yeah you know wait
so
and then she gets the box from auntie
britt with the jessica simpson box with
the boys
toys that's what i'm saying like this is
wilder than like this is not like a boom
boom boom
fact fact fact it's layered there's so
much like also like conspiracy on this
and like
obviously something's not adding up
adding up
and like britney did not send you a box
of used
like toy monkeys and a jessica simpson
shoes and then she tagged her like gigi
she sounds like really small but she's
liking every post even though it's shade
to her
well i think she's trying to counteract
the narrative that it's about her
no it's super confusing and also i kind
of love that um
brittany called out this performance
where jamie lynn
remixed all of britney songs because of
course i went on a search i'm like what
is she talking about
and it's from a few years ago at the
radio disney awards where there was like
a medley a tribute oh i posted it you
went on a search you went to my stories
and you clicked
i did see it before it was on your
stories on tick tock
oh really i did get it twice from your
stories yes thank you thank you
you guys the cringiest so cringy it was
like a tribute all these disney stars i
saw like
i can't believe i'm doing this with my
arm right now this is just showing you
how much i want to show you something
cringy it was and brittany's mom have
you ever seen lynn spears this is so
happy in her life like
it just made you like feel like wait did
she does she love
jamie i have a hot take yeah i thought
jamie sounded good in that in that video
like i thought she was really giving it
her all like bopping i thought her hair
looked amazing
she looked like a britney impersonator
she does look like
and brittany's like yeah brittany's like
this is weird but he's like i'm alive
yeah
i don't get it i'm out of the house i'm
happy like let me just clap no but
it did i mean and why was she i mean yes
can we agree that she looked like she
was cringed out yes but like
then why did the dad force this like
none of it makes sense when the dad
wants brittany to make the money because
he's making money like
i'm not a self-proclaimed like good
researcher i'm just like here is
everything weird happening
yeah yeah yeah you know what i mean so i
don't know like
i'm waiting i'm really waiting for
brittany to be like okay y'all
this is what happened because otherwise
how are we gonna know
yeah but you know what i think for a
while there's been so much speculation
about whether or not brittany runs her
own instagram because some people felt
like it was like propaganda from the
conservatorship
but after this last week i'm pretty sure
now we're all in agreement that she does
run her own instagram
but when she then go on stories and be
like hey
i think there's so much at stake that
like she's willing to share
but like she has a mission and that's to
get out of her conservatorship yeah and
she's not going to post anything crazy
on social media that could derail that
i think you know claudia i don't know at
the end of the day we're
spewing [ __ ] like we don't know
really like her sami
posted the vid first of all daily mail
post said she's driving around in her
mercedes which some people dm me that
in the first hearing she said i just
want to be able to go on
but does she have her license i'm sure
that may be
why well people were saying that she
said she didn't which i didn't remember
from the
the testimony but um so dailymail put up
her and her white benz which like i
remember that
car yeah i feel like it's always been
that car i don't like i just love
learning things about printing she
drives a mercedes
yeah and sam put up they were listening
to lonely
thinking about the time that i was dead
and britney said that was like a song
she was really really and then she
riffed
stop you didn't hear the red no but did
that video get taken down
yes five minutes freaking after
yeah how do you feel about sam i feel
like he's a very unsung hero of this
whole thing
i hate like i'm
people are gonna be like no i really
don't want to conspire if i don't have
to so like i want to believe first of
all
it also doesn't make sense like why
would he stick like you're like oh he's
using her
why there's clearly no benefit she
doesn't get any money
right she's never picked it out for the
long haul like
it doesn't make sense so i feel like
it's for real and i feel like
i feel like it's for real and you think
he wants the best for her i do
i think so too i'm i've been in my head
he does also want to be like an actor
and stuff we all sorry he has dreams
okay
we all have dreams and he's just getting
there faster
i mean not even for sure he's derailed
now because he's
now trying to save his girlfriend yeah i
mean there is and i feel like to be by
brittany's side i mean you have to be
strong you have to be patient you have
to be willing to
deal with this craziness so i feel like
if he's there
i mean then people are like is he paid
but if he's paid would he like
put up the free brittany but then it's
like oh but maybe they're trying to but
then you're getting into like just
crazy town i don't think he's paid at
all i think he's actually been
integral in britney's kind of making so
much progress in the last couple months
in her conservatorship
in being open with the public i think
that you can give him a lot of credit
for that
yeah and you just wonder like behind the
scenes it was up for like 10 minutes
no you just know what the like i'm dying
to know like what the [ __ ] goes on in
that house like i would
love to be a font in the wall just like
even in the dancing videos like i'm just
so curious about how we got here what he
said
that's really important because i was
also one to like kind of make fun of the
dancing videos
before like we kind of realized what was
happening with brittany i'd be like oh
this is so funny oh it looks kind of
crazy oh
that's kooky what is she doing okay so
brittany on stage
versus brittany in these videos write
huge contrast
imagine you dancing
in your room and filming it wouldn't it
look crazy
oh my god i would look like a moose
right it looks so stupid
like i feel like if you know in your
head when you sing you sound so much
better than you do so i feel like to me
i'm like oh i can do this choreography
and then if i would do it and there
would be a camera on me i'd probably
look [ __ ] nuts
yeah i i honestly never really got on
the train of like hating those
videos just because there's always just
been this very strange and we've known
about the conservatorship for a while
but i think like social media and just
the free britney movement has made it
like such a prevalent conversation in
the last year
but i just i don't know i felt bad for
her for a while oh your alarm
that sound just triggered a million
people myself included i'm sorry
honestly
could you just take a moment my chest
hurts that sound like really i'm really
sorry and it's for my zoloft so
you need to change the sound like do i
like it's triggering
you're trying to find and that sound is
just like interrupting all the progress
you need to take it you need a minute
it's not here oh okay well don't forget
it
don't forget it yeah um so that's our
free britney recap of the day i'm sure
in the following weeks there'll be so
much more to discuss but this weekend
was a busy one
for the spears's and their iphones
then we're going to move into our little
kardashian segment there's two
kardashian stories we want to talk about
one is obviously kravis because you are
the biggest kravis stan of all time is
that correct do you take that from like
the fan accounts of like kravis forever
11 year olds yeah
well courtney and travis say no we're
not engaged at least
not yet and this story comes from tmz so
we know it's legitimate
and it comes after there was really not
any legitimate sources but like okay
magazine was posting that they were
engaged
there was a lot of weird things
happening with travis's daughter alabama
posting on instagram like i'm so happy
for you guys
but they're setting the record straight
kourtney kardashian and travis barker
had the internet buzzing with engagement
rumors
after their recent weekend together in
las vegas but it just ain't so
the couple took in conor mcgregor's
gnarly loss to dustin poirier last
weekend
where they made out ringside but it's
what happened back at their hotel that
had people talking
travis's daughter alabama posted a so
happy for you guys photo of court and
trav smiling
and fans assumed the best that the
couple was engaged to be married however
we've spoken to multiple sources aka
chris jenner
um they all tell us the same thing
travis and courtney are a happy couple
but he did not put a ring on it yet
as for why alabama posted the pic she's
happy to see her dad happy
so um i really feel like you should get
on tick tock because al i follow alabama
she's
really active and i kind of feel like
she's living
for her dad being like so buzzworthy
right now and she's just kind of like
wanting to get involved that's what i
would do
if my dad was dating a kardashian like i
would literally be thirsting out like at
the house hey courtney when i have
dinner like
i would do anything be posing pictures
of courtney so i respect the thirst but
i do think this was
um somewhat like you know stirred up by
alabama not to blame it on like a child
i posted like a throwback video when she
was really little and travis is kind of
like a stage mom too really
like he was literally like she was like
seven maybe they tried to have her come
out with like a song i don't remember
but they were like interviewed
and he was like alabama tell like the
interview
like where where'd you have dinner last
night and she's like oh i had dinner
with jennifer lawrence
corny kardashian so she she was like
into it from that so i could see that
how old is she 15. oh my god i thought
she was so much older she's very mature
with her glam and her long nails yes
very very glam um and
i first of all didn't believe the
engagement rumors and like
i just hate rumors that are just made up
yeah me too it's so annoying it's so
annoying
you know like making up the courtney's
brand with twins just hate it
by the way you started a conspiracy
theory on your instagram i remember that
courtney's pregnant with twins and i
joke though i believe it she's playing
into it too like
everything she's posting like two
cheerios tea hot tea hot tea
slurp it up hot boarding toast
um oh my god i'm such a choke okay
what's the tea gotta go
um okay so you know when she posted this
was so on purpose
you know when she posted the number two
on the frickin table yes
that was like come on yeah she's playing
with us okay
so i responded to her story as i started
to do since we became friends and i was
like you're [ __ ] with us did she
follow you
no but she like interacts with you yeah
okay so i was like you're [ __ ] with
us
right and she's like wait claudia you're
gonna i saw you did you put this on your
close friend's story or
on your regular story i have one of
those oh i thought i was on it
and i wouldn't violate her you need a
close friend just here
she's on my podcast this one she doesn't
know okay so she said
ha oh my god smiling emoji smiling emoji
smiling wanted smiling emoji cats
smiling emoji cat smiling emoji because
she's a very emoji
girl that's chewy that's a little bit
jokey and she was like i didn't even
think about that that's so
funny like she knows that we know yeah
no no
she knows that there's a while like she
knows about this stupid conspiracy
theory that i don't even know how he
started it don't say we you started this
don't bring me into it don't bring me
into this you started
so and i was like the twins are on your
mind
she's like i love it she was like i love
it it brings a smile to my face
so she likes it do you think courtney
will ever get married because i know for
sure they will
you do i mean even when things were good
with scott she did
she didn't want to get married i feel
like because she have we ever seen her
like this though no it's
crazy i mean it's like they
the the inception of the post sharings
alone like she posts a post he shares
that she shares his chairs he shares the
share that she shared with a little
black card
like that's and then he like shadow tags
it's just wild and then
they comment each other's things like
the post would be like i love you
initial comment i love you in holcomb
and i love you
yeah it's like it's a lot they're so in
love like they're i don't i'm not gonna
be shocked as much as i'm the number one
fan when the engagement does happen
yeah i'm gonna be like oh they're
engaged yeah you know what like
i'm so interested by them because they
they remind me a lot of of course megan
kelly
no megan i mean that's a good machine
gun that's what we call that miguel and
kelly
but what are their names megan fox and
machine gun kelly like
so hot so fast every picture of them
spotted was like viral viral viral
and honestly those things really fizzle
out really fast like you get over
someone so quickly
the public does and then they get over
each other but with courtney and travis
and also
meegan kelly like they're two of my
favorite couples and i love that they
keep hanging out like
it's literally the best thing of all
time and courtney and travis have not
fizzled out like i really
remember when they were so hot and heavy
on the bus and he's posting pictures of
her ass in utah like
i'm like this is a lot and i'm loving it
but it's gonna fizzle out like people
just get over things really quickly
not fizzled out even in the slightest
remember how long they were friends so
it's like they still
have that foundation like even if the
sex
chills yeah then they still have the
foundation of being friends for so many
years
do you think that the rumors that um
[Music]
kim and travis had hooked up were true
yeah
but kim said on her q a that they
weren't okay but you know what else
the cr um all the jenners and
kardashians once were asked if they
hooked up with justin bieber they all
said no and i'm pretty sure like three
of them hooked up with
courtney did i feel like kendall did one
hundo
i saw this tick tock actually because
you guys i'm like a sleuth and sometimes
people send me tic tacs so i'll watch
them
and literally it'll jump up like
download the app and i'm like no no and
i'll like watch it on something you need
to download the app it's so gross you're
just like
no it's an old person not willing to
change their ways i understand but like
you
are an influencer you're a podcaster
like you gotta roll with the times girl
like
please you will love it okay okay i'll
think about it
well um can i like be a troll on there
and then
people just like engage with the content
they don't make
they consume they don't produce um so i
saw a tic tac that was like
really hardcore and i don't know what
this girl was trying to get up but it
was showing how like
kendall and jb did hook up and how he
was like basically going from kendall
to hb to selena back to hb so what i saw
for sure in this like
evidence-filled tick-tock was that he
did like
go from hb to selena so i imagine
there's like a lot of turmoil there
i have actually seen this tick-tock
because i've seen every tick tock and
it's about the girl who like goes on his
instagram all the way down and like
shows the photos
yes and like there was a lot of kendall
in there and there was a lot of like
intimate kendall so one hundo so i don't
believe
i feel like they don't spill the tea and
there's so much that we so yes i think
that
i mean if travis went on like he was
interviewed and was like i think kim is
so hot
i think she's so sexual she's my type
it's weird
i feel i mean it's even that alone um my
ego so big like could you ever
never well you have sisters like yeah
what are your thoughts on
sisters like hooking up with the same
guy what even if it's years apart it's
so weird
couldn't so it's incest it's
twisted put it but like not even hooking
up the fact that he was like she's my
type her
body what do you mean he said like i'm
dating paris sure but like kim that's
like he's like you can't stop looking
no it's imagine how does courtney chill
with him and kim no it's
it's horrifying no no no no no there's
definitely something going on there
um well we're moving so slow because
we're just like talking but i'm not
living for it no that's okay we've
i have nowhere to be you have a child
you probably have somewhere to be um
so we have another little kardashian
story um
that's brought to you by purple doesn't
it seem like the world is against us
from getting a good night's sleep this
time of year oh my god the sweating is
real
but when you have a purple mattress you
can sleep cool and comfortable no matter
what the world throws at you
there is a heat wave that like never
ends here in new york so it's important
that everything in your bed is working
for you not against you keeping you cool
that really includes your mattress as
well because purple mattresses have
the grid a unique ventilated design that
allows air to flow through
to help you sleep cool even when it
feels like a thousand degrees out
and the grid is amazingly supportive for
your back and legs while cushioning your
shoulders necks and hips
no matter how you sleep unlike memory
foam which remembers everything the grid
bounces back as you move and shift
so you never get that i'm stuck feeling
you do with memory foam
um also i have a lot of purple uh
pillows and they're everything of the
sort they're
so comfortable obviously like they're
firm but soft but also when it comes to
keeping me cool i always wake up with
like a sweaty neck but ever since i got
purple um pillows i don't have a sweaty
neck and then i don't have to take a
shower in the morning which is so nice
so purple's making me not shower try
your purple mattress risk-free with free
shipping and returns
financing is available too purple is
comfort reinvented and right now you'll
get 10
off any order of 200 or more go to
purple.com
tmt and use the promo code tmt
that's purple.com tmt promo code tmt
for 10 and 10 off any order of 200
or more purple.com tmt
promo code is tmt terms applied all
right
so after many a rumor that kylie jenner
was pregnant
she's stuck what are you do you need
water no i'm good
oh i thought i always take a breath oh
my god
what is breath i don't know her kylie
jenner
stuns and shows off her curves in a tiny
gold bikini after the star responds to
pregnancy
rumors so there were some legitimate
theories running around that she was
pregnant but she just
shut that [ __ ] down with a picture of
her looking so unbelievably snatched
in a gold bikini that made me just want
to
um i don't know like grab a knife and
cut my stomach out you know
so with this one i feel it i feel like
it's a sterile
i'm like i feel mystically that it's
true you think she's just trying to like
veer us off
posted a blind that like a sister is
pregnant
um yeah a famous family and she's using
like it's
like a cooperation to use like old
things
well i got a dm from someone that was
like i
know for a 100 fact that kylie's
pregnant like i work and blah blah and
i'm like
yeah but then i got a damn that was like
saw her yesterday
and you know yeah i know that's why i
don't take it but i don't know like my
feeling is
her and travis are back together yeah i
feel like there they are
yeah i feel like they are and they
stormy is like
two yeah which is the age where
typically you can start kind of like
uh what does that mean oh so usually
like when people have kids they want to
like space them in a way so i feel like
two is like the where you it's like the
good space
um and i don't know why i have this
feeling maybe she's posted less thirst
traps
and then okay so this is what i think
she's posted less
thirst traps and then when we were all
like is she pregnant she posts three in
a row
yeah and she probably has a content bank
of thirst yeah
so i'm wondering like is she posting
them to be like no you guys i'm not it's
for sure related to the rumors
either to shut them down or to throw us
off right
exactly so i don't know which one but i
don't know why i have a feeling like it
might be true
um even though i really want to say that
i don't like pregnancy
conspiracy speculation just because like
i know but like with this this is not
based on like anybody's body
this is not based like on fertility like
i i
that's why i usually don't like it but i
don't know why it's been i feel like
quarantine has been such a couple like
it's been
everyone got pregnant everyone got
pregnant everybody does um i don't know
why i feel like with kylie
and travis it's gonna come but yeah they
don't i mean i hope so like i know kylie
wants to have more kids and
stormy is too so i would love that for
her and you know what
i don't know i'm just obsessed with her
like whatever she wants to do like would
say tyler
for me kylie i don't know story
sherman doesn't talk oh and kylie you
just know her personality
so well did you watch like did you watch
the life of kylie
no you never watched life of kylie would
i like her
it's it's super interesting isn't it so
i've been like a kylie stan like i used
to be obsessed with her snapchat i was
like really invested in her
when the whole lip kit thing like
started for when she was on vine like
right when she was becoming like
everyone's favorite kardashian um and
it's always been like very clear that
like the kylie we know from instagram is
actually like not kylie at all she's
like a very weird interesting
personality
and every now and then like it does peek
through and you got to see it a little
bit on life of kylie
but life of kylie was like a lot about
jordan woods like a lot about her
friends remember like
when kylie was obsessed with her friends
and like didn't really hang out with her
fans yeah well they made a comment about
on the last season which i love
i love too um so life of kylie is very
much representative of that era in
kylie's life which was not my favorite
because i just really like lo
i'm so family oriented and i wanted
kylie to be that way and like she did
she had to learn those lessons said in
the reunion she was like i realized you
guys were kind of cool and they were
like about time
but so life of kylie did give you a
little bit of an insight into like who
kylie is
she does have like a really interesting
personality i think that never gets
shown on social media why
or but or on the show yeah but she's
like never even on the show but when she
is she's like the memories
well so remember how when she first she
was on the show for a while and then she
got lip filler and then she became
famous and like disappeared from the
show
yeah she i think i i don't know this for
sure i think she's like so
traumatized by like how much [ __ ] she
got for getting lip fillers at like 17
like the world just like
really came for her um and now that
she's successful and doesn't need the
show she doesn't like give people much
of who she is
huh but that's just that's a conspiracy
theory i mean her and kendall both don't
give anything
nothing like imagine like when you
podcast or when you
are interviewed you're like it doesn't
look like it but we're
really trying to go hard over here like
yeah like i'm sweating
and they're they'll just sit there and
be like yeah no it's really great
yeah literally and they'll just like bl
and that's what i'm shocked at like a
little
actually impressive how far they've
gotten by saying so little
you know i'm jealous um that's your
kardashian conspiracy theory news for
the day i can
not promise that we won't have more by
the end of the week you know there's
always literally like you were saying
before like how all these rumors just
like start it must be something that's
like literally the life of a kardashian
you wake up and there's like all these
fake stories about you
it would drive me nuts it really and i
really hate when people say like chris
jenner
because the devil works hard that's chew
gay
that is that's so toogy yes
because she's and didn't you hear on the
thing she's like i don't have time for
that
yeah and i believe her you know and it
seemed like that was a thing that really
bothered her that she's like this master
manipulator when she's really just like
a mom who wants the best for her kids
i refuse to see chris jenner as anything
other than that people see her as this
master of spin i see her as like a mom i
agree
i [ __ ] love her and what do you think
about her and corey i'm obsessed with
i'm obsessed with her if she i had to
pick a favorite it would be kris
jenner i literally completely and like
her style and like i'm sorry she looks
the best
out of like all of them like like the
work she had done is so
perfect and like everything just looks
so good i love when she wears like
combat boots
and i just love all of it and her vibe
and she's just such a good
time oh my god if i had to go out for
drinks with any of them it would 100
percent be chris and corey
so corey you like him he knows that stop
me and jackie are absolutely wine he
just seems like first of all he's been
so unwavering like in his support of
chris and he
you saw on the show like was a little
awkward in the beginning with the girls
because like he was younger but he is
like so tried and true and i feel like
he and kylie get along really well and
he supports chris so much i mean there
was a little weirdness there though no
like wait get along or also like the
palm springs car thing when he like
kicked kendall out of the car or
whatever like
oh we don't know what actually happened
he doesn't like kendall no i
i stand in defense of cory gamble like i
think he's an amazing guy and like an
amazing boyfriend and look how happy
chris is
yeah they she hasn't never dated anyone
else after
caitlyn besides corey for years three
years there's proof in the pudding i'm
sorry like it's true we all thought it
was weird of course like
younger guy but i'm sorry there's proof
in
the long-term stable relationship that
they have i think he makes her happy and
supports her and isn't like trying to
breathe
or be true he's not thirsty i'm telling
you
we all need to take more time to respect
corey gamble because he is a really
honorable man i'm telling you
i mean okay so travis you know i love
him number one stan and like i might be
wrong because i only started following
him when courtney came into the picture
but like i wonder a lot like i think he
really loves her but
all of these he's producing for every
single up and coming forever
he was on jimmy kimmel he's do like
opening brands every day yeah and it's
like wait is this like
thirst moment i just have to say a
moment his song with willow smith is
unbelievable
i need to listen it's called transparent
soul it's the best song of all time like
wait i need to ask you a question as if
you were on my podcast
yeah who would you go for then
travis or mgk if you had to pick a
knight machine
kelly like i'm obsessed with him oh
you're so obsessed
he's so handsome like i can't stop
smiling now you're asking me about it
no like i'm obsessed and i love his
music like i'm i was a fan of his music
before like i even saw his face you know
that's a lie but you know
okay obsessed you got to get into it i
need to get into it
listen to the song bloody valentine it's
you'll like be obsessed with him in two
seconds
really yeah okay so good um okay
i really could talk about the
kardashians all [ __ ] day but there
were other things going on in the world
so from page six this is really
interesting new york city socialites are
running scared from the bbc's galaine
maxwell docu-series
manhattan's upper crust were
tight-lipped about colleen maxwell when
a team of bbc filmmakers
hit the town this month we hear sources
tell page six that producers of an
upcoming bbc documentary on jeffrey
epstein's alleged madam
and her late shamed press baron dad
robert maxwell
were in the big apple to interview
subjects this month the filmmakers
managed to land an interview with david
boyes a famed attorney for the epstein
victims
as well as various business associates
of robert including a former pr rep and
executive who once helped
her father robert maxwell by the new
york daily news high society types who
once rubbed elbows with galen and
epstein are running
scared and keeping mum an insider told
page six
all members of higher society in new
york refused to talk to the bbc
some people are buying copyrights to
photos both in london and in new york
to remove the pictures from the market
that shows them with galain
and or epstein and another source
familiar with the project told us
i bet that people in new york city high
society are not lining up to speak to
the bbc
so this is what's really interesting
when the whole good lane thing happened
if you go to
gettyimages.com or like any paparazzi
bank of photos
and search her name you will find her in
photos with
any celebrity like and that's why
there's literally a picture i mean
there's an instagram account like elaine
and her celebrity friends
because you see like literally everyone
with galen that's like
well do they know her or she was just
like such a thirst monster at all these
high society events that she got invited
to because of her dad
that she would just take pictures with
celebrities like there's a lot of rumors
about her and like carol radswell
they've been pictured together many
times and i do believe they were friends
so
i think that i'm i thought that the
netflix documentary on jeffrey epstein
was really good but
didn't give us enough insight onto the
celebrity element because
all there are a lot of famous people on
his plane manifests going to his island
a lot of pictures of him with a million
celebrities him and galen
so i hope that this documentary tackles
what i thought the netflix one
missed out on a little bit also the
netflix one like made
the netflix documentary was made like so
quickly after he died that like i don't
think there was enough time for like
all the developments like they made it
too soon now it's been a couple years
and there's so much like evidence that
the the federal government has i think
it'll be more
i think that the netflix documentary was
more about the victim so we've heard a
lot of from the victims
but yeah it's very interesting to get
the take of like the celebrity aspect
because we also like contests
right but um like right was it like
pictured at events
because if they went to the island then
they knew yeah
if you were on the island then you knew
if you met them at an event maybe you
didn't know
of course no if you were on the plane
manifests like girl what are you doing
well that's what um i forget which
victim it was in the documentary said
like she
was so traumatized by what happened she
stayed in her villa
and she like left the house and she saw
bill clinton
sitting like at the pool with like an
underage girl so and i feel like they
didn't really dive into that at all it
was just like an anecdote mm-hmm
but i think there's a lot that went on
and like friends
yeah like people from all over in
politics in business celebrity movies
there are people from all walks of life
that
were on those manifest and i think that
there's a lot and i'm i think that's
what it sounds like this bbc
documentary is trying but who's fleeing
do we have any names
no but i can imagine if you ran in a
fabulous crowd
10 years ago and you you know we're at a
party and you met a girl and you took a
picture with her like you do not want to
be involved
in this [ __ ] show yeah it's so layered
like
from the island to jeffrey like fake
killing himself
no one knows or like getting killed or
like running away and he's like living
in cambodia or something he's definitely
alive
um i can't imagine any person wants to
be a part of this
right and i i imagine they're having a
very hard time making this documentary
right and but they can't force people to
speak so why are people running oh they
want to be like oh
i wish i could talk to you but i'm in
i'm sorry i have no reception
you're waking up well i'll definitely be
watching that documentary
very soon um okay fourth story
this is really interesting and we
haven't spoken about it yet but
apparently they've been dating for quite
some time
renee zellweger and aunt anstead are
making out on the beach
um they've been photographed a bunch of
times making out like on her balcony
they were just photographed on the beach
making out and for those who wonder why
we care
ann anstead was married
to christina what's her last name
anstead
oh right right right but what's her like
what's her famous name
oh yeah oh she was christina musa yeah
she was married to tariq el musa they
had a show on hgtv together
not enough people know about this they
had like the police were called to their
house
tarek like grabbed a gun and left the
house and ran up the mountain or
something
then they got divorced and everyone's
like what about their show flip or flop
which really isn't that good
they kept the show it was all about like
co-parenting while also flipping and
flopping homes like whatever
then she got remarried really really
fast to this random
british tv host ant anstead he then
obviously took his time and now is
engaged to heather ray young
from selling sunsets yeah so they made
you know they're still engaged speak of
two ghee
speak of two thirst monsters like for
real they're tick tocks make
you have to get on tickets oh no i can't
no i can't handle it okay no no i can't
handle it so christina moved on really
fast
had a baby with and and then got
divorced like super super fast and now
and said
who was dating a reality star is dating
literally
renee zellweger a renowned oscar-winning
actress and i'm just
so like i think this story is so twisted
like
is ann antstad the biggest social
climber of all time how did he get here
is who is he is he cute yeah he's a very
handsome
like silver fox he met renee he's
hosting like a discovery plus
show called like iou trips or whatever
and i guess she
got paid to do an episode because i
can't imagine that's something she would
want to do she
got so much hate for like do you
remember like like
her face yeah i [ __ ] hate when people
say that yeah
because you're like no no one's getting
face transplants no and you know what
like if i was renee zellweger and i had
all the money in the world you bet your
ass like if i'm getting older i'm
getting a face transplant
and no one can tell me otherwise for
real what's wrong with the face
transplant
if it's my choice people think it's like
that movie like it's yeah like yeah did
she do some this and that
um tariq al-musa
first of all what a last name it's like
so uh
like kind of regal right yeah so no he
um him and heather ray young were on my
podcast actually like a day after i
posted that they were huge
jews because they went to nobu and took
a picture
like underneath the nobu sign that is
you had them on your podcast
yeah i gotta listen no you're gonna hear
this
no you go babe oh my god i swear
that's literally like everything that
you thought
it was like no stop but she came on with
a baseball cap
and her hair in the thing she's the most
gorgeous barbie
you've ever seen like no but on the
thing i was like are you [ __ ] kidding
me do you record video
record a video so i'm with them they're
like hugging and he's like babe
you tell them how we met on the boat
called i regret that from like he has a
boat called like last night
i was drunk like some weird regrets from
last night like something i was like
you're such a tool like i don't i think
i might have said that really too so he
met her on a boat
and no babe stop you like they're like
that oh my god
not even joking but no but it was like
you know when you're like wait this is
real because this
is how they are yeah and i also at the
end of the day like when they got
together i'm like oh this is thirst
meeting thirst
but i'm sorry there is proof in the
pudding right you have a long stable
relationship with someone and the more i
see them like damn
they're they're not rushing into
anything they've been engaged for a
while like
christina ran as fast as she could away
from tarek
got married and engaged in two seconds
and it didn't work out yeah so there's
proof in the pudding i'm sorry like yeah
if you're together for so long
that's why i hate when like there are
rumors about sean and camilla not being
for real
yes because i'm like they're together
for like so many years and so in love
what do you think you're a hater you're
a hater you're a champion
hater i feel like i'm not a chamilla
hater at all
i love them oh i definitely don't love
them
i'm not gonna lie like i am confused by
them okay and i just
will never forget at the beginning of
the pandemic when they were like posing
for paparazzi pictures going on their
walks with their mugs and then the video
of them maybe they weren't posing okay
then a video came out of them
as they're walking for the paparazzi and
they're walking in slow motion
for me that was kind of like the end of
the cuteness but what if they were
really sluggish in the morning
listen you don't have to tell me about
sluggish i'm literally the laziest [ __ ]
alive
i walk 30 times faster than that and i
walk slow okay listen
i don't know i think he's cute and i
think she's cute me too i mean
i feel i literally in my mind invented
camilla cabello i watched x factor no
seriously
i watched x factor i think i did watch
that season two was
obsessed with fifth harmony they used to
be called l-y-l-a-s
lylas that was their original name i was
obsessed she was so clearly better than
every single one of them like
she slipped through the cracks in the
audition process like she must have
[ __ ] up
like when they were doing the auditions
and like then she ramani is amazing too
oh my god amazing but normani did not
shine
at all until after she left the band
like she was
really not even like i don't even
remember
her being better than any of the other
girls for me it was always
vocally and on x factor she got all the
solos she got the bridges
she's behind us all the other girls were
like swaying behind her like clapping
and snapping
i was obsessed when they left x factor
they had like a weird interim time
before they like started releasing their
music they were releasing all these
covers on youtube
they're amazing you have to go watch
them and still it was like camilla was
the star camilla was the star
then the band happened camilla was a
star when she left i was not surprised
at all
so i'm love camilla cabello i'm the
biggest taylor swift fan i love that
i love their friendship something about
this relationship doesn't sit right with
me i don't know what it is i'm sorry i
can't put my finger
on it but i just want it's not like i'm
biased because i'm obsessed i'm
i'm like did you hear the video that she
they put on tick tock
yes i did about her running do you not
like it i just wasn't inspired and like
i'm a body positivity like
queen and i just and usually like i get
like i tear up i love seeing body
positivity content you didn't i was like
i was like this is like lame
i was just like i wasn't inspired i was
but and i'm just trying to prove like
i'm not biased against her because i'm a
huge
i've been a huge fan on the video so far
and you've hated on the relationship so
maybe but i'm not gonna reconsider
but i'm not a hater that's one for her
i'm trying to be objective
okay i really am because i love camilla
yeah she's so cute
she's so cute yeah but i don't know
something's just about it's nice
sean it's possible i i didn't love his
documentary like we get it
we're getting humble you're from toronto
that's not
being from toronto is not a personality
trait i'm sorry and he was just like
toronto toronto toronto toronto
don't get me wrong the hottest man alive
yeah he's so hot and like
john mayer vibes john mayer vibes and
did you like die when he went to the
gala with haley baldwin i know it was
fake but for like that one moment that i
believed it was real
no but that they had those pictures
hugging after it was completely fake
he's why he spoke about it in an
interview like
they were friends and it was really just
like a publicist thing like because it
was it was made them both huge you know
what's crazy that was like literally she
got married like a month later i think
i'm just realizing which i know people
won't believe
like how because we're realizing now
courtney huge right travis big
together so i'm just realizing now how
like
couple power is like a real thing
because i never got remember there were
always rumors like why
two hollywood stars are like put
together like i i never got it until
like we're seeing
how how how much power there is in a
power couple no and like that's really
what's the fun part about being a
celebrity is like who you date can like
really raise your star
like if i was famous would you ever date
somebody not famous yeah if i wasn't
married like i would be like
literally running all over town like oh
my god i was [ __ ] if i wasn't married
i'd be
sliding into so many dm i'd be hooking
up with people from like copy paste
like 100 every blue check mark like
everything i would be messy on instagram
about it like i would definitely use it
to my advantage it's really
it's so cool like i mean madison lacroix
is on
a show and she's famous from the show
but what she does outside of the show
makes her even more famous yes
she's on the show right she didn't have
a lot going on she's one of an ensemble
but she's like so if you want that
messiness would you want math
i wouldn't do the instagram live level
oh my gosh but i would be messy for sure
like why not i'm like young and fun and
like fabulous i would be like messy as
hell
um we've got one more story a little
rumored dating news that's brought to
you
by glamnetic oh i'm excited about this
i'm wearing my glamatic nails right now
you know i'm obsessed with press-eye
nails
glamnetic if you have any struggles with
your lashes finding the perfect lash for
your eye shape
or the grueling application process it
can be exhausting and frustrating
and that's why glamnetic has put in the
work to craft beautiful lashes for every
eye shape
and they've made application easier than
ever it's done in seconds and really
super easy all you have to do is take
their quiz to find the perfect lash
for your unique eye shape and style and
you'll never have to show up late again
because of
the clarinetic magnetic lashes they take
under a minute to apply
there's no toxic glue and no struggle
and you can use
each lash up to 60 times so they're
super eco-friendly and wallet friendly
they have over 75 styles to fit your
perfect natural glam
and you can get a different different
lash for every mood and occasion they
also have brown lashes which is perfect
for blondes and redheads
take their lash quiz or use the lash
guide to find the style that suits you
and before you check out make sure to
check on their press-on nails i'm on
like
no you sold me i want them i'm a press
i'm on a press-on nail like journey
how cute are these i want them and they
style them like after celebrity nails so
like they have like different ones that
like kylie's had it's really cool okay
wouldn't go that far but
find out for yourself why glamnetic
lashes are instagram's favorite beauty
hack go to glamnetic.com
toast and enter the promo code toast if
you want to get 30 off your order
the code's only available for our
listeners that's glamnetic.com
toast enter the promo code toast at
checkout for 30
off all right final story is a little
news about adele
she is rumored to be dating an nba agent
rich
paul rumors are flying after the two
have been seen together
the grammy winning singer and sports
super agent
rich paul sparta sparked dating rumors
by sitting together at game five of the
nba finals on saturday
which ignited into a full bone-blown
blades after espn's brian
ward windhort windhorst
referred to adele as paul's girlfriend
so he was on the
on his um podcast he said rich paul
libera oh my god i can't [ __ ] speak
do you have a stroke
let me just start again reset reset
rich paul lebron james you don't have a
stroke that's a test if you have a
stroke
i thought it like helps you speak better
i'm it's working i'm keeping my hands up
rich paul lebron james's agent brings
his girlfriend to the game sitting next
to lebron
his girlfriend is adele that's what he
said word for word on his podcast
he said rich paul is at the game with
adele so they were spotted together
which made people think that they were
dating
then the podcast guy
said said that they were dating so she
has a new man who's like a rich like
businessman
for her that's what i would do by the
way sorry i know i said i would slide
and slither into like
but whatever it takes time to settle
down but i would want like
a businessman so we have a like who is
bella hadid dating
we have a phrase here at the morning
toast called the businessman bow
and that's like the in our eyes like the
ideal type of man to date
for a powerful woman because so many
guys like thirst you out
and we really thought honestly like jlo
and a-rod were a great example of like
having a businessman boy but he turned
out to be like such a thirst monster
and such a sleaze but there and we
always say courtney khloe kardashian
needs to find a businessman beau because
she's always dating people who are
taking advantage of her
you need like the the like the yeah like
the man
like who's stable art collector yes
so i think this is a perfect example of
a businessman bow for adele well who did
she date before what was
he he was she was linked to a rapper i
think we spoke about that a few weeks
ago who i hadn't heard of
i'm sure she's just playing the field
but i do kind of love this
for her a businessman beau i love it
first of all love adele which i know is
like who doesn't love adele yeah it's
not
like it's not like a right she's so
beautiful
and so talented but like we need some
songs i know and so i'm kind of loving
that she's going through like multiple
relationships after her divorce because
we want songs full of highs
and lows we want you know pop anthems
where she's happy and then like
devastating ballads when she's sad
yeah so i'm here for her making the
rounds totally i feel the same way about
casey musgraves like after she
got divorced she's you're not you've
never been into her
oh my god you have to really yes
okay she's everything and she's like one
of the greatest songwriters of our time
up there with adele i would say
and she just got divorced and she won
grammy for album of the year
got divorced and now she's working on
music she's been spotted linked to two
different guys
so i want the same thing for her as i
want for adele like lots of emotions
multiple relationships
that can become inspiration for songs
yeah you know
totally so i think that this is a great
match but
page six obviously really really really
really really really good for kim
oh let's talk about that do you i i
don't know
they were spotted together by the way
who came in kanye
with the kids with the kids okay yeah
this is like i didn't even post it which
like if you know me i'll post anything
kardashian related right but like this i
was like yeah so they're with the kids
it's not a big deal yeah it's not a big
deal but when it comes to kimchi
the businessman beau model is very
interesting i think kim is so
stable remember how on the last episode
of kardashian she said
calmness is my superpower oh my god she
almost got killed and she was like
so calm grateful for the experience like
no she's like for all that it taught her
she said it was meant to happen to her
do you remember when she said i'm so
happy it happened to me i'm not saying
courtney because she wouldn't be able to
handle it or any of her sister she said
i feel the opposite of kim i feel like
my soul is weak
100 like i would literally like
literally i can get like
trauma from like from a walk in the park
this morning exactly exactly so like
when she said that i realized like how
weak i am yes and how not calm i am like
i am
my superpower is being frantic all the
time like i panic at a moment with
notice
die for that like i would die for it so
i think with a businessman beau
it might be two it's meant to balance
out like a very powerful woman whereas
like kim is a very powerful woman but
she is a business
woman herself i don't know if the
businessman beau model would apply
well to her what does she need i think
she just needs like a mega star
you know who's very humble like like a
kanye
brad pitt oh my god if kim ever dated
brad pitt i would lose my mind she does
she needs
somebody maybe like yeah she needs like
like someone strong
and like that can like handle her but
also someone fun and outgoing because
kim is really serious
and i think that was like a really good
part of her relationship with kanye was
like he was kind of like
goofy goofy and he made her laugh and
smile all the time and i think that was
like why
one of the elements of what made their
relationship work for so long yeah so i
think she needs someone like goofy and
silly while also on her level
i really want to see her dating like i
really hope we get to see that
you know there were rumors that she was
linked to van jones but they like shut
that down
yeah um and then also maluma like they
were like spotted out i don't think
there was anything to it
no but i kind of liked the luma what are
you feeling about scott and amelia's
camellia
me and jackie um we refused to like kind
of really acknowledge him on the toast
because it's so inappropriate
and like it's it's really not an
appropriate
age gap i mean technically though it's
legal yeah of course
just because it's legal doesn't make it
appropriate and so we really just like
well didn't you love his explanation on
the reunion
they thought he was gonna say something
like insightful right
and then he was like the young girls and
i mean at least call them women or
something yeah i know
but then calling them girls i was like
no scott which i have been going on a
hater role about him lately i
feel i feel it and i feel like anything
he does now
and i really am trying hard to not have
it rub off on amelia because i don't
think she deserves it
yeah but i sometimes cannot but do you
watch real housewives of beverly hills
no but i feel like i really should
honestly you should for this season one
because there's so much going on with
erica
and kathy but also they talk about scott
and amelia you know and lisa arena who
is a self-proclaimed thirst monster she
calls herself she's a hustle hustle
hustle do a depends commercial anything
for a dollar
she's worked in this industry for so
long because she takes gigs no one wants
she's spoken about that for
years yeah she's very open about how
like in la
in hollywood you have to hustle hustle
hustle like you'll be irrelevant in five
minutes if you don't work and if you
don't make money
and you know she married harry hamlin so
financially they're fine but
she's all about the hustle like she
jokes about it all the time whatever
and so when they're filming is when
scott and emilia are first linked and
she brings it up in the car with erica
and then brings it up with her friends
and she's like pretending to be
disapproving harry hamlin the hus the
father
is not happy about it he does nothing
like the age is appropriate
but lisa's like living for it because
she's she's sick she knows the hustle
she knows what it takes to survive in
hollywood and
being linked to a kardashian gives you a
five year extension
she's pretending to not be into it she's
like pretending like oh i don't know
what to think
girl we know you're thrilled yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
we know because she has to because if
she's like all for it then she has to
play the game she has to play like
and then at the end she'll probably be
like oh but he's a good guy like she'll
like
she'll take us through the process of
like approving of him 100
yeah so those were the past five stories
i definitely feel like there was a lot
to catch up on from the weekend i'm so
glad we got to get your expertise
thank you so much for being here you
live here now i know
i know you have a child so like it's
really nice of you to come in like
really an hour here no it is like i
really appreciate it so
if you enjoyed amanda's take on
literally everything kardashian
check out her podcast not skinny but not
fat and also her instagram she posts
like
you literally like are the you have so
many [ __ ] stories have you have you
ever reached so many stories that you
can't add more
it's like 100 right yeah does that
happen to you a lot no but it's happened
i wish you would post more like i'm
obsessed
i get all my news swear to god
kardashian from you she can you stop
making me a kardashian fan account you
are no i'm not
yeah i i i some like if i'll have like
probably a normal amount it looks weird
to me i'm sorry you're a hilaria baldwin
stan account
i [ __ ] want that reality show i know
that's what
people that are smart need to get like
networks need to get on that
yeah but people killed their podcast i
don't know it was so mean
oh what happened with their podcast well
no it just like had one star reviews
after like
like people are just a trailer they're
not listening to it they're just hating
yeah well do you think that she's of
latin descent
no okay i think it's wild it's one of
think things i can't sleep at night
me too i think it's so cringy and weird
it's so weird
okay well make sure to follow amanda
because she posts a lot of kardashian
content but a lot of other content too
honestly you're a hilaria baldwin
investigator a free britney advocate
you're a justin and hayley stan and you
are a kravis stan you're very
well-rounded i'm sorry to have limited
to pigeonhole you
but her instagram is everything it's at
not skinny but not that and that's what
our podcast is called too
great guests check it out thank you so
much for being here
thank you guys for listening and
tomorrow we've got another special guest
co-host you won't know who until
tomorrow so
make sure to i don't know just keep up
with us thank you so much for listening
to the morning toast
the millennial morning show where we
deliver the past five stories that you
need to know every monday through friday
on youtube so if you're watching this on
youtube
please feel free to subscribe and give
this video a thumbs up we're also
available as a podcast anywhere podcasts
can be found so it's spotify itunes
stitcher public radio i heart radio cast
box
all the places so whenever you listen to
a podcast find us the morning toast
leave a five star review about how
beautiful stunning and smart we are
hope you guys have an amazing day and
we'll see you tomorrow goodbye
bye i'm shocked at how quick you did
that